في وقت تسعى فيه اوروبا تعويض امدادات
الطاقه الروسيه المقطوعه تعرض الجزائر
عليها بيع طاقتها الفائضه من الكهرباء هذا
ما اكده الرئيس الجزائري عبد المجيد تبون
في مقابله صحفيه مع وسائل الاعلام المحليه
رئيس الجزائري قال ايضا ان بلاده تخطط لمد
انبوب طوله 270 كلم تحت البحر باتجاه
ايطاليا
احنا نقدر نحنا عليهم
اقترحنا هلا بالدور صديقه
اننا ندير كابل
يربطنا يربطنا باوروبا في اقرب نقطه معي
طبيعي 270 كيلو متر
الرئيس
مليار متر مكعب سنويا بعد ان كانت 56
مليارا في 2022 من خلال هذا المساء
استقبلت الجزائر عددا من كبار المسؤولين
في الاشهر الاخيره
بقيمه اربعه مليارات دولار ينص على تقاسم
انتاج النفط والغاز في حقل بجنوب شرق
الجزائر على مدى 25 عاما وخلال زياره له
الى الجزائر
بالدوله العربيه الواقعه في شمال افريقيا
الى الجزائر في اكتوبر الماضي ان اوروبا
تريد شاركه استراتيجيه
طويله الامه